the film opens in 1982 showcasing the
vast icy expanse of Antarctica a small
snow cat Maneuvers through the ice field
with three Norwegian scientists on board
sounds like the setup for a very stupid
joke they're trying to track a
particular signal initially everything
appears normal as they exchange jokes
and engage in a casual conversation but
soon after their device emits a strong
signal so they decide to stop and
investigate the area but before that the
ice beneath them begins to crumble
causing their snow cat to plunge through
into a fisure where it becomes wedged in
the next scene we are introduced to an
American paleontologist named Kate Lloyd
who is currently examining a creature at
her lab during this she is visited by
two researchers a Norwegian scientist
named Dr sander hon and his assistant
Adam Finch who tells her about their new
discovery a structure and an organism to
conduct a detailed study they need a
paleontology ologist so they ask Kate to
accompany them to Antarctica which she
agrees to following this the team boards
a helicopter and heads towards the
Norwegian camp in Antarctica with Pilots
Sam Carter and Derek Jameson and Kwan
Griggs on their way Sam informs them
that they need to wrap up their mission
in a couple of days due to an
approaching storm after some time they
land at THU station where they are
welcomed by a mechanic named Lars who
doesn't speak English wasting no time
Lars drives the team towards the
designated location a thousand-year-old
ice cave upon arrival they are welcomed
by a group of geologists led by the
station Chief named Edward vulner Edward
introduces them to his team members
before guiding them deeper into the cave
soon after he shows them a high-tech
spaceship that was found inside some
distance from the spaceship they show
Kate a strange alien-like creature
encased in a large block of ice which
leaves her in shock this is way more
believable than that they found in
Mexico back at Camp they discussed the
removal of the creature which they
believe will take at least one day the
following morning the team excavates the
Creature from the ice block and
transports it back to THU station DR
Sanders orders the team to firstly take
a tissue sample for the investigation
Kate opposes this arguing they need to
do sterilization and take other
precautionary measures however Dr sander
tells her not to contradict him in front
of the team following this they drill a
hole into the ice extract a frozen flesh
sample from the creature and securely
store it later that night the team is
celebrating their Discovery when Dr
sander announces that he has never seen
a creature with an exceptionally High
cellular level like this he believes
that the entire team will be remembered
by the whole world for this
groundbreaking discovery as he continues
talking the ice block containing the
creature starts to melt lars's dog
senses something aess and incessantly
Barks in an attempt to escape its space
but fortunately lars's dog doesn't speak
English either shortly after Jameson
comes out of the bathroom and goes to
the room with the ice block much to his
surprise the alien creature bursts out
from the ice block and escapes through
the ceiling this movie was originally
going to have practical effects like the
original but the producers with
all the money said no CGI so we're left
with this garbage you know Jamon
anxiously goes back to his team members
and alerts everyone about the incident
they all hurry to the room and stare at
the ceiling in shock because nobody
thought that the alien would be alive
after thousands of years after this Dr
sander directs the team to split into
twos and threes and search for the
creature one pair investigates the dog's
kennel and discovers a large hole in the
wall along with blood and fur another
pair Henrik and Olaf spots the creature
beneath one of the wooden Huts upon
closer inspection the creature resembles
a large Beetle which is slimy has multi
craike legs a large mouth with giant
teeth and tentacles all the fans in
Japan say yay as soon as Henrik turns
his back to the creature one of its
tentacles pierces through his chest
splattering blood on Olaf's face the
creature then drags Henrik back under
the Hut and begins digging on him Olaf
screams out of fear prompting the other
team members to rush to the scene they
instantly open fire on the creature but
it has little to no effect on it it
simply jumps onto the hut climbing
through the walls in a desperate attempt
to kill the creature the team douses the
Hut with kerosene and sets it on fire
burning the creature to death in the
aftermath of this event the group
returns to their Cottage and Mourns
henrik's loss Olaf seems to be
traumatized by the incident and as a
result they decide to transfer him to
the city for medical care despite the
team's lack of confidence Dr sander
emphasizes that studying the creature is
their responsibility as scientist s
following this Dr sander and the entire
team bring the remains of the creature
and Henrik back into the room with
Kate's assistance Dr sander proceeds to
dissect the creature as they cut into
its tissue they see the upper half of
henrik's body inside it and Kate
comments that his skin looks almost new
just then Kate discovers a metal piece
and asks about it henrik's colleague
explains that Henrik had a titanium bar
inserted into his arm to stabilize a
fracture Kate further questions why the
bar is outside instead of being within
his arm but nobody knows the answer
later on as Kate and Adam examine the
creatures tissue under the microscope
they make a startling Discovery the
cells are not only still alive but they
are overtaking henrik's cells and then
replicating them the next morning Carter
and Jameson prepare the helicopter to
transport Olaf while Kate is still in
the bathroom there she notices blood
stains on the floor she uses a tissue to
pick up four bloody silver Dental
fillings upon checking the shower she
finds a lot of blood but no body in the
meantime Olaf and Griggs get into the
helicopter with Carter and Jameson and
the four take off Kate hurriedly rushes
outside to stop them Dr sander questions
her act and she insists that they
shouldn't leave thankfully Carter
notices Kate signaling them so he
decides to land just then Griggs is face
unexpectedly splits in half classic
Griggs and his chest opens to reveal
tentacles and RI likee teeth he soon
transforms into a monstrous creature and
attacks Olaf causing the helicopter to
crash into the mountains seemingly
killing all four members after
witnessing this the rest of the team
members try to seek help from outside
Antarctica but the approaching storm
disrupts communication channels edford
decides to relocate all the members to
the second Camp meanwhile Kate goes to
the bathroom to inspect the blood stains
only to find them mysteriously vanished
someone on the team has a sham wow
perplexed she goes back to the team and
urges them not to leave because
something strange is happening Kate
explains her theory that the alien can
clone a person by replicating human
cells in addition she claims that the
reason why metal stuff is found outside
the victim's body is because they cannot
be replicated by the aliens however her
warnings fall on deaf ears and everyone
exits the room except for Juliet later
Juliet lures Kate to an abandoned room
where she reveals herself to be the
alien creature she launches her attack
on Kate but the ladder somehow manages
to escape out of the room while running
through the hallway she encounters Carl
and tells him to run however he doesn't
and as a result Falls victim to the
violent creature no Carl as Kate shuts
the door to the hallway Lars and Adam
arrive with some weapons LS holds a
flamethrower and burns down the creature
afterwards while disposing of car and
Juliet's bodies Kate explains that the
creature operates like a virus anyone
coming into contact with its blood or
part of the creature's cells gets
assimilated however she's not sure of
its solution So Adam suggests that they
quarantine themselves until the threat
is eliminated Dr sander then insists on
a blood test to identify who may be
infected after this Lars and Kate
disable all the snowcats while Adam and
Dr sander work in the lab before you
comment saying this is just like a mug
us just no the thing came first the same
night Carter and Jameson arrive at the
camp after surviving the helicopter
crash everyone believes that they must
be the creatures replicas because they
couldn't have just walked away from such
a dangerous crash one of the team
members named pedar even points a gun at
them but Kate intervenes she suggests
that they be confined into a room until
their blood samples can be tested when
the team returns after locking up the
pilots they discover that someone burned
the laboratory with all the blood
samples in it panicked they start to
accuse one another but Kate comes up
with an idea to conduct another test she
grabs a flashlight and proceeds to check
everyone's mouths those with dental
fillings are deemed safe as the
creatures replicas can't replicate
inorganic materials the suspects are
narrowed down to Dr sander edford Colin
and Adam who lack Dental fillings my
money's on Adam Adams are always CG
replicas Kate holds the molet gun point
and instructs Lars and his friend yonas
to get Jameson and Carter in the next
scene the two head to the building
holding the pilots only to find the
place empty it turns out that Carter and
Jameson have escaped through a hole in
the floor Lars begins to search for them
but he's suddenly pulled into a building
following this yonas rushes back to
inform the others presuming that Carter
and Jameson have killed Lars shortly
after Carter and Jameson re-enter the
building where they have a standoff with
pedar meanwhile the rest of the team
hides themselves behind pedar edver
orders pedar to execute the pilots
claiming that they're the real enemies
but just as pedar is about to pull the
trigger Jameson shoots him in his head
during this he also hits the
flamethrower tank which causes an
explosion the blast throws edver away
causing him to be severely injured with
Carter and Jameson now in possession of
all the weapons they compel everyone to
enter a room with two members carrying
the wounded edford once in the room
edford suddenly under goes a violent
transformation of being the creature it
launches its attack on the rest of the
team members fatally injuring yonus and
Jameson in the process soon after the
creature gets a hold of Adam and starts
absorbing his body to become even more
powerful Kate and Carter try to get the
flamethrower working but are unable to
do so due to the trapped air in the main
fuel line once repaired Kate attempts to
burn the creature assimilated with Adam
but it escapes outside with her heart
filled with guilt she she Burns yonas
and Jameson before they can fully
transform the main threat now is the
replicating creature infused with Edvard
and Adam meanwhile Dr sander hides
behind a desk for protection but the
creature attacks him infecting him as
well on the other hand Carter and Kate
split up while pursuing the creature the
former heads to the kitchen and the
creature suddenly appears just before it
can attack him Kate uses a flamethrower
to force the creature to burst through a
wall causing it to fall into the snow
outside they then successfully burn the
creatures assimilated with Edvard and
Adam while observing the charred remains
they noticed the infected Dr sander
driving away in a snow cat Carter
suggests letting him go saying that he
has nowhere to escape as the storm will
freeze his body however Kate disagrees
pointing at the risk of him infecting
others if he manages to leave Antarctica
as a result the duo get into the other
snowcat and follow sander to the
location where the team first discovered
a spaceship as they step out of the
vehicle Kate notices Carter's earring in
his left ear while conversing he tells
her that they didn't kill Lars they then
explore the open space of the spaceship
which suddenly activates its movement
causes Kate to fall underground
rendering her unconscious a few moments
later she wakes up and finds herself
inside the spaceship surrounded by
pixel-like entities floating in the air
while observing these pixels the
creature assimilated into Dr Sanders's
body emerges from behind and pursues her
into a tunnel Kate hides in a corner
where the creature cannot reach her
there she spots a grenade and grabs it
but before she can use it the creature
grabs her leg and pulls her out of the
tunnel after a desperate struggle she
somehow throws the grenade into the
creature's mouth exploding it into
pieces why does it even have a mouth the
impact of the blast triggers the
breakdown of the spaceship system
causing it to shut down after this
intense incident Carter and Kate exit
the ice cave and decide to drive towards
a Russian camp located 50 m away just
before she gets into the vehicle she
notices that Carter's earring is missing
raising her suspicion maybe he just
realized it looked dumb to make sure
Kate asks him to point out where his
missing earring is located when Carter
points to the wrong ear Kate concludes
that he's infected as well as a result
she incinerates him with the
flamethrower as he burns Carter lets
loose an inhuman screeching noise
following this Kate boards another snow
cat before driving away in the final
scene a helicopter lands at the ruined
THU camp where the pilot Matias
discovers a lifeless and Frozen man
seated by the radio it turns out he
committed the unthinkable mathas yells
out to see if anyone is around and a
gunshot startles him it's Lars the only
one left behind and not infected
suspecting infection Lars demands that
mathas show his tee just then lars's dog
which was previously killed emerges and
runs away realizing that the dog is the
last standing creature Lars orders
Matias to start the helicopter they then
pursue the dog and Lars shoots his own
pet from the helicopter hell of an
ending hell of an ending no Carl Carl
not Carl God damn it no Carl subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching